signori oggi usiamo una tecnica molto
particolare che voi avete già visto qua
in questo in questo senso che questo un
green screen no perché la magia della
tecnologia oggi la utilizziamo nei video
che noi questo stesso procedimento lo
utilizziamo non è vero nello stesso
marcellina gx perché ti permette di di
vedere attraverso le persone e se tu sei
un controllore dell'areoporto vedi
attraverso la gente che che spa una
bellissima le cose proibite giorno 1 non
ho letto va bene un importate rio sono
una persona che gli occhiali a raggi xe
deve vedere le persone deve arrestare
questi sono i livelli di qualcosa
oggetti proibiti armi e coltelli va bene
vediamo questa è una farfalla c'è la
farfalla va bene la fa il pallone
previta questi kozuch anno qua una
matita va bene niente un sapone a posto
cosa c'è a lei mi scusi con pesce non
fosse come normalità è un pesce a posto
vada vada madonna che casino
raga quanta gente c'è non sono da solo
fermi fate una fila comp che schifo fate
una fila compatta per lavori di gesù vi
prego è armi è restata una bomba una
bomba
restiamo lo non puoi portare bombe anche
tu falso arresto non restano che non
doveva restare li mortacci mia o ragazzi
difficile fare il controllore
no non è una bomba questa sì che abbonda
maledizione per via ma come è una bomba
a cellino puoi usare a posto
ce l'ho fatta giorno 2 le cose le armi
sono accettabili ma non le banane
ehi ma perché banane ed plans cosa sono
i clan si aspetta enuncia che non ci
sono quei cosi che fanno ed plans non mi
ricordo cosa sia
questa post dice la bastiglia sapone
farfalla a posto niente banane sul mio
aereo schifosi a posto con le armi
potete passare niente banane sul mio
aereo vi ammazzo
niente banane vi ammazzo ok cos'è sta
cosa sono gli ex plans non lo so aiuto
va bene con la bomba poi passare niente
banale niente clans non solo siano di
ike lanza aiuto non so cosa siano vi
prego di stermino a mano a barare non ce
n'erano però ecco che tu sei così cosa
ti amo estero un'aragosta non a posto ho
sbagliato mamma mia quanto difficile ma
ve li faccia apritevi ripartire da zero
di volta ok armi e coltelli va bene
allora facciamolo per bene tu armi via
caneva una bomba tua sorella falso
arresto dopo allora le bombe possono
passare perché non sono considerate armi
scusatemi non lo sapevo io coltello
coltello con te non puoi con la bomba
potevi ma il coltello no non l'uso
eccola la banana porco demonio avessi
vista prima ok ok le bombe poi passare
tranquillo tutto a posto spetta farfalla
madonna ragazzi un casinò a armi via
dopo la bomba sia posto vai vai vai vai
benissimo benissimo armi che gioco
stupido ragazzi non fate queste robe in
aeroporto perché sono poi la colpa mia
che vi facesse non fate cose non si
portano alle bombe in europa tutti si è
incastrata se tentato di resistere a un
arresto cosa fai
e ti sei accorta che per casoli è la via
giusta quanto hai bevuto sull'aereo di
pippa no come una persona è passata con
le armi con un coltello non l'ho vista
va bene
giorno 2 ritorniamo allora niente banana
ed plans alex sa che cosa vuol dire ed
plant in italiano barana via un porco
demonio grazie all'ex seriamente
incredibile paravia banane via porco
demonio porco demonio le banane banana
via quante para ne esistono banana via
cava ca tu con la bomba sia posto
ok cos'è banano sapone sapone a posto
bombe cosa va bene non ciak enuncia che
via via non c'è che non va bene aiuto
aiuto non so cosa siano le belle
l'inning nel lag plans tutto bene con le
matricole fetta fatti fino alla matita
nella trachea
va bene armi a posto va bene va bene
puoi passare poi passare per passare non
so cosa siano gli ex plans questo sta un
po di uovo sono me è una garanzia ma
deliziano sbagliato pare non ci siano
banane bene ce l'ho fatta pur non
sapendo cosa fossero gli ex plans va
benissimo prossimo ragazzi questo il mio
lavoro hanno sbagliato a farmi farlo
youtuber niente serpenti niente vermi e
niente lobster lobster credo sia
aragosta ok matita va bene serpentino è
porco demoni serventi mi ammazzo
ma come è sbagliata dall'altra parte ma
come lobby che lo apprendo che la fatica
franciosi c'è gente che va da una parte
dall'altra non si di scemi nova e si
cassano tra di loro pure ma come a
serpente via anche aragoste via e porco
demonio lobster
vermi verni pure ma eccolo xvi sa bene
posso ok lobster via via via via via via
aragosta via ce l'ho fatta c'è solo un
serpente va bene ragazzi dovreste andare
da quella parte mi spingo io dovete
andare madonna dritti ritrito spostati
ma perché la gente si incastra solita
gente va via
ok le granate e le bombe vanno bene ma
non le uova le uova no ok oggi fermiamo
tutte le uova signor cracco mi scusi
nole questa nuova queste sono bombe
vanno benissimo a posto vada vada è
difficile perché questi sono tutte le
bombe quindi non esco a vedere le uova
sono che hanno la forma delle bombe le
uova quindi è difficile trovarle che
casino a posto posto occhio che questa
corre pure a posto uovo attenzione non
si fa ok ok bomba posta normale
incastrate tra di voi ragazzi siamo
serve un casinò a cosa cosa ma cosa
pensa di fare lei ma pensa di essere
nell'azienda di giallozafferano ma cosa
ha capito via fuori dalle balle con le
uova le uova non passano di qua schifosi
maledizione nuovo mamma mia melo melo
preso in tempo
meno male che vinca strade tra di voi se
lo sarebbe veramente difficile a posto
tutto bene quel che finisce frittata
risposta te signore lei è pelato non so
se n'è accorto e una signora mi scusi i
visi incastrate per favore che non
finisce il livello dunque dovrei aver
fatto tutto è teoricamente bene giorno 5
o non l'ho sbagliato nulla
niente smartphone va bene niente
smartphone
vediamo come vi riconosco di che casino
madonna soap avere quelle ai colonos ma
è uno smartphone quello e la piastra
della papera non è lo smartphone quindi
via perfetto si incastra tra le papere
lo smartphone cos'è quello mi scusi è
uno smartphone via porco demonio
ci mancano solo gli smartphone che non
sono smartphone non portate le papere
che poi un casino maledizione non devo
far passare nessuno
smartphone occhio lei non passa mi scusi
che si può fa come si vuole qua qua
lavoro io ho eccolo con un altro
smartphone via no lei ho sbagliato non
ho sbagliato ho schiacciato sulla
persona sbagliata ma chrome e prega che
mi far iniziare di mino voglio morire
no però bello tutto insomma c'è nel
senso un po irreale perché secondo me
secondo me le uova non a prescindere non
devono passare però e per il resto tutto
perfetto tiene di provare un gioco più
tranquillo si chiama ai film fantastic
vediamo ho scaricato dallo stesso sito
vedo che è stato sviluppato da gente con
un cervello perfetto vediamo
[Musica]
chigi